Welcome to the DevOps Nanodegree.
I'm Julia,
a Project Manager here at Udacity.
I will be guiding you through your first
steps in learning more about DevOps.
DevOps developed organically from people
who are at the forefront of developing
software for the Internet.
These people came from all
different types of backgrounds.
Some might have a similar
background to you and
some might be completely different.
But they all have a single goal
to improve collaboration and
efficiency throughout
their organizations.
DevOps is a practice that emerged from
agile development and lean management.
One thing all of these systems have
in common is continuous improvement.
DevOps is not just about buying
software or holding a one day training.
It's a journey that will take time,
effort and commitment.
You'll need to balance the needs of
many different groups within your
organization as you implement
wide scale cultural changes.
Well, it's up to you to take the first
steps, we will be here to support and
guide you along the way.
In the process we'll look at tools
that can help you manage some of
the technical challenges.
Although DevOps won't magically
solve all of your problems,
following DevOps practices will help
your team to improve collaboration and
work flow throughout the whole
software development life cycle.
DevOps did not become popular because
somebody forced its adoption.
It's popular because it works and
it makes teams and
companies more successful.
Excited to learn more?
Let's jump in.